we did some research here are some other corporate emails that mistakenly got sent out recently for example Walgreens emailed ladies for the entire month of October at make plan be your plan yeah ancestry.com emailed the rumors are true your great-uncle was John Wayne Gacy yeah overstock.com emailed nobody else wanted this [ __ ] maybe you will air B&B emailed September is stay with a murderer month he the murderer XE emailed we heard you make crappy earrings sell them on our site Omaha Steaks emailed for a limited time only try our roadkill sampler and finally Joseph a bank emailed up to 40% off suits that will help you sneak past security on to any college campus [Music] you you